.
>> Jesse: HEY, BRET, THANK YOU.
♪
>> Jesse: A LOT OF THINGS GO
UNNOTICED IN LIFE.
YOU MAY PUT IN A FEW EXTRA HOURS
AT WORK AND YOUR BOSS WILL TELL
YOU IT'S PART OF THE JOB.
YOU MAY FEEL GOOD ABOUT YOUR NEW
HAIR CUT ONLY TO FIND OUT NO ONE
REALLY CARES.
BUT PEOPLE WILL ALWAYS NOTICE
JUST HOW MUCH MONEY YOU STOLE
FROM THEM.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THESE
PEOPLE WERE THINKING.
I DON'T THINK THEY REALIZE THAT
BESIDES WEALTHY INVESTORS, THEY
WERE HURTING MIDDLE CLASS
INVESTORS, RETIRED POLICE
OFFICERS, FIREFIGHTERS, IT'S
OUTRAGEOUS.
>> HIS TOWN OF FAIRFIELD
CONNECTICUT TO BERNARD MADOFF'S
LIST OF VICTIMS.
A TOWN OF 58,000 PERSON PENSION
FUND JUST LOST 42 MILLION
OVERNIGHT.
>> Jesse: HISTORY SURE HAS A
WAVE REPEATING ITSELF.
SOMETIMES IN BIGGER WAYS.
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY FINDS
ITSELF IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
BIGGEST FINANCIAL FRAUD CASE IN
U.S. HISTORY.
A CRYPTO CURRENCY COMPANY, YOU
KNOW, LIKE THE BITCOIN THINGS,
JUST LOST $2 BILLION OF ITS
CUSTOMERS' MONEY.
THEY DIDN'T JUST LOSE IT IN THE
MARKET.
IT'S JUST GONE.
SOMEONE STOLE IT.
AND THE COMPANY CALLED FTX JUST
WENT BANKRUPT AFTER THEY BLEW UP
$32 BILLION.
>> THE CRYPTO MARKET AND CHAOS
AFTER THE COLLAPSE OF THE FTX
EXCHANGE WITH THE NEW SET OF
QUESTIONS ON WHERE BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WENT.
A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION OF ITS
FOUNDER SAM BANKMAN-FRIED HAS
BEEN OPENED IN THE BAHAMAS.
>> THIS IS BEING CALLED THE
WORST DISASTER IN THE HISTORY OF
CRYPTO.
>> THIS IS BIGGER THAN BERNIE
MADOFF BUT UNLIKE BERNIE MADOFF
WHO WAS GETTING RICH OFF A
PONZISCHEME THE DEMOCRATIC PARTS
GETTING RICH FFX.
CAME ONTO THE SCENE IN 2019 AND
SPENT $10 MILLION TO PUT JOE
BIDEN IN THE WHITE HOUSE IN
2020.
AND THE GUY RUNNING FTX, THE
SECOND BIGGEST DEMOCRAT DONOR IN
THE MIDTERMS AFTER SOROS, OF
COURSE, SPENT $40 MILLION TO GET
DEMOCRATS ELECTED.
WONDER WHY SOMEONE LIKE JOHN
FETTERMAN WAS ABLE TO RAISE HIS
AS MUCH AS FOUR TIMES AS MUCH
CASH AS OZ?
WELL, YOU CAN THANK SAM
BANKMAN-FRIED WHO RAN THIS
CRYPTO SCHEME OUT OF A PENTHOUSE
IN THE BAHAMAS.
>> MY NAME IS SAM AND THIS IS MY
STORY.
>> SAM HAS CRAZY HAIR.
SAM IS VEGAN.
SAM SLEEPS FIVE HOURS A NIGHT.
SAM LIVES IN THE BAHAMAS WITH 10
ROOMMATES.
SAM IS 29 YEARS OLD.
ONLY BUT SAM HAS $22 BILLION.
AND HE WANTS TO DONATE ALL OF IT
TO CHARITY.
>> Jesse: THE CHARITY WAS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
LOOK AT SAM RIGHT THERE BEHIND
GEORGE SOROS.
SOROS PAID FOR A CRIME WAVE AND
SAM MAY HAVE COMMITTED A CRIME
TO STOP A RED WAVE.
THE GUY WAS THROWING SO MUCH
MONEY AROUND THEY GOT THE OWNER
A SEAT RIGHT NEXT TO CLINTON.
GOT INVITE TO BILL'S AFTER PARTY
WITH CELEBRITIES LIKE KATY PERRY
OF COURSE.
CLINTON HAS REALLY GOT AN EYE
FOR MEGA DONORS.
FIRST EPSTEIN.
SAM BANKMAN-FRIED WHO THEY CALL
SPF.
IF YOU SPEND ENOUGH MONEY ON
DEMOCRATS THEY DON'T CARE HOW
YOU GOT THE MONEY AS LONG AS IT
GETS TO THEM.
ALL THE CELEBRITIES WERE JUMPING
IN, TOO.
LARRY DAVID WAS DOING
COMMERCIALS FOR THE GUY, TOM
BRADY AND GISELE WERE
AMBASSADORS.
HE WAS JUST AT THE WHITE HOUSE
ACTUALLY.
GOT TWO CLOSED DOOR MEETINGS
WITH BIDEN'S SENIOR ADVISER IN
THE SPRING.
RIGHT AROUND THE TIME BIDEN WAS
SHIPPING BILLIONS TO UKRAINE.
THE FUNNY THING IS UKRAINE WAS
INVESTOR IN FFTX.
WHY IS A COUNTRY IN THE MIDDLE
OF A WAR INVESTING IN CRYPTO?
SHOULDN'T THEY BE BUYING
WEAPONS?
IF THEY HAVE TO INVEST IN
ANYTHING DOESN'T CRYPTO SOUND
RISKY FOR ZELENSKYY.
YOU WOULDN'T WANT AN INVESTMENT
WITH SOLID RETURN AND STABLE
GROWTH.
ZELENSKYY THOUGHT HE WOULD GIVE
TO A GUY LIVING IN A TAX HAVEN
FRESH OUT OF COLLEGE WITH FUN
CANNY HAIR.
WELL, WHEN DEMOCRATS ARE SENDING
YOU BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
WEAPONRY, THE LEAST YOU COULD DO
IS REWARD THEIR FAVORITE MEGA
DONOR.
WHAT DID FTX DO WITH THE MONEY
UKRAINE INVESTED?
THEY PLOWED IT RIGHT BACK INTO
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
DEMOCRATS SEND MONEY TO UKRAINE.
UKRAINE SENDS MONEY TO FTX AND
FTX SENDS MONEY TO THE DEMOCRAT
CAMPAIGN.
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS WAR
PROFITEERING OR MONEY
LAUNDERING.
I DON'T KNOW.
IT NEEDS TO BE INVESTIGATED.
AND WE DON'T REALLY KNOW WHO IS
GETTING WHAT BECAUSE SPF LIKES
HIS MONEY IN THE DARK.
>> SO, I WANT TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT
FOR THE COUNTRY.
>> YOU THINK EVERY MONEY YOU
SPENT IN POLITICS SHOULD BE
DISCLOSED PUBLICLY ARE YOU
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT.
>> IF THERE WAS A NORM THAT
EVERY DOLLAR EVER DONATED TO
POLITICS WAS TO BE DISCLOSED
PUBLICLY I WOULD HAVE A LOT OF
SYMPATHY FOR THAT, I THINK I
MIGHT SUPPORT IT.
I HAVEN'T THOUGHT ABOUT IT
CAREFULLY ENOUGH TO KNOW.
>> MAYBE THERE ARE DONATIONS
THAT YOU HAD MADE THAT YOU
WOULDN'T MAKE IF YOU KNEW
IMMEDIATELY PUBLIC.
>> SO I THINK -- I DON'T
GENERALLY THINK ABOUT IT THAT
WAY.
>> Jesse: CAN YOU BELIEVE CHUCK
TODD?
FIRST THEY FALL FOR AVENATTI AND
THEN THEY FALL FOR THIS GUY?
WAS IT EVEN HIS MONEY TO BEGIN
WITH?
IT LOOKS LIKE IT WAS INVESTOR
MONEY HE WAS SPENDING ON
DEMOCRATS.
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
REPORTS FTX WAS CRACKING INTO
CUSTOMERS' ACCOUNTS AND USING
THEIR FUNDS FOR OTHER STUFF AND
THEN WHEN CUSTOMERS WANTED TO
WITHDRAW THEIR MONEY, A LOT OF
IT WAS GONE.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND SCC
LAUNCHED AN INVESTIGATION
BECAUSE THIS LOOKS LIKE THE MEGA
DONOR ALSO LIED TO CONGRESS.
>> WE HAVE A TRANSPARENT SYSTEM
WHERE ALL OF OUR DATA IS -- ALL
OF OUR PUBLIC MARKET DATA IS
OPENLY AVAILABLE AND FREE WHERE
RISK PARAMETERS ARE TRANSPARENT.
>> Jesse: SO TRANSPARENT.
DID HE THINK HE WAS TOO BIG TO
FAIL BECAUSE HE HAD REGULATORS
IN HIS POCKET?
PROBABLY.
YOU'RE BULLET-PROOF WHEN YOU CAN
BUY POLITICIANS.
THIS GUY WAS PLANNING ON BUYING
BIDEN WITH A BILLION BUCKS.
>> I IMAGINE HAVE YOU SOME
PROBABILITY DISTRIBUTION IN YOUR
MIND OF HOW MUCH MONEY YOU MIGHT
GIVE IN THE NEXT ELECTION CYCLE
LIKE GIVE ME SOME NUMBER.
>> I WOULD GUESS NORTH OF
100 MILLION.
>> SO IF THAT'S THE FLOOR.
WHAT'S THE CEILING LIKE A
BILLION?
MIGHT YOU GIVE A BILLION?
>> YEAH.
I THINK THAT'S A DECENT LIKE
THING TO LOOK AT.
>> Jesse: SO THE DEMOCRATS'
SECOND BIGGEST DONOR JUST BLEW
UP RIGHT AFTER HE HELPED
DEMOCRATS KEEP THE SENATE.
OOPS.
THAT'S A SHAME.
PERFECT TIMING FOR CHUCK SCHUMER
THOUGH.
BUT THIS WAS A FAMILY AWARE.
THE CRINGT TOE FRAUDSTER'S
BROTHER HAS A JOB IN CONGRESS.
OF COURSE, HE WORKS ON THE
FINANCIAL SERVICES COMMITTEE AND
WORKS FOR A DEMOCRAT.
SO THE GUY IN CHARGE OF
OVERSIGHT IS STAFFED BY FAMILY
MEMBERS OF MINI MADOFF.
WHATEVER HAPPENED TO THE
32 BILLION ANYWAY?
I WONDER IF THERE WAS ANY RED
FLAGS?
OH, HERE'S ONE THE PERSON
RUNNING CASH FLOW AT FTX ISN'T
GOOD AT MATH.
>> I USE VERY LITTLE MATH.
I USE A LOT OF LIKE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL MATH.
>> SO I SEE THOSE ABSTRACT MATH
CLASSES ARE NOT -- ARE NOT
REQUIRED.
>> I NEVER HAVE ALL THE
INFORMATION SO YOU HAVE TO MAKE
YOUR BEST GUESS BASED ON WHEN
YOU SEE.
>> WE TEND NOT TO HAVE THINGS
LIKE STOCK LOSSES.
I THINK THOSE AREN'T NECESSARILY
GREAT RISK MANAGEMENT TOOL.
YEAH, TRYING TO THINK OF A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF A TRADE WHERE I HAVE
LOST A TON OF MONEY.
UM, WELL, I DON'T KNOW.
I PROBABLY DON'T WANT TO GO INTO
SPECIFICS TOO MUCH WITH THAT.
>> Jesse: HAD YOU EXECUTIVES
BRAGGING THEY DON'T DO RISK
MANAGEMENT.
[LAUGHTER]
AND THAT, BY THE WAY THAT WAS
MINI MADOFF'S GIRLFRIEND.
SHE WAS LIVING IN THE PENT HOUSE
IN ONE OF THE WORLD'S FAMOUS TAX
HAVENS WITH HIM IN THE BAHAMAS.
THERE WERE 10 KIDS WORKING IN
THIS OFFICE AND THEY WERE ALL
SLEEPING WITH EACH OTHER.
IT WAS A POLYAMOROUS PENTHOUSE.
A DUMP SCHEME.
NO ONE NOTICED A THING UNT